au collège en quatrième ça je vais je
faisais du théâtre et j'ai une copine
aussi qui faisait du théâtre avec moi
elle a fait un téléfilm
donc tout ce que je me suis dit moi je
voulais travailler jouer bien dans ma
vie tôt et quand je vais faire du talmud
y tient
acteur ça va être bien et cette coquine
caf un téléfilm j'ai dit c'est quoi ton
là j'en ai mal à passer l'adresse de son
agence mais je vais m'inscrire à la
gencive ont pris et m'ont fait faire un
casting
ça n'a jamais marché quand arrive déjà
t'es pas à l'aise et nettement moins à
l'aise déguisements lorsque tu fais là
c'est que tous les huées
j'en ressors ils disent on va t'appeler
t'attends pas coûter fin de la semaine'
taille rien donc ça commence à m'énerver
qui a rien pour nous allons donc là
aussi c'est pas pour moi ton pied et
puis là on m'a repéré dans la rue
là par exemple on a vu plusieurs
plusieurs offices et puis il y en a eu
une elle est rentrée dedans officielle
celle qui va faire le film parce que
cordiale et si tu veux l état donne des
émotions qui font le vrai tout le temps
et pas d'un temps de jeu donc c'est
l'impression que la vérité quoi que
c'est vrai que c'est pas quelqu'un qui
est en train de faire cette image in sur
un autiste par exemple le super dur
c'était quelqu'un qui fait genre motif
qu ils croient pas ton fils est mort
c'était différent de tous les autres
castings
déjà première entente aurait pleuré je
me dis pleurs je n'ai pas pleuré pleuré
ça fait longtemps vous arrêtez de
pleurer mon frère il m'a dit faut que tu
pleures qui longtemps et puis en fait
au bout d'une heure et demie tu m'as
fait pleurer je vais taper sur un canapé
je me rappelle plus trop et un peu un
truc
mais d'abord je m'appelle on se devait
taper sur un canapé et puis ça monte ça
monte et puis après c'est venu se
passait à prendre l'a fait la promo
pression mais je suis ressortie été
vidés quoi sur sortie cassini si jamais
vécu en question comme ça at elle aussi
dit ok d'accord de cinéma située
pour moi je me rappelle stéphane strass
paillettes pour moi avant avant de
rencontrer des signes matin puis après
c'est clairement tu rencontres ans on va
montrer c'est quoi vraiment cinéma et
puis j'ai vu que c'était du travail
jose alors c'est bon tu jamais séparés
je me suis tu
et après
salois plus rien quand je suis voilà
vous soumet une plaie à l'eau rébus tués
je
après tout le travail qu'on a fait en
fait ça a consisté à te apte à prendre
un peu des fondamentaux plus pour ton
existence propre que pour apprendre à
devenir un acteur ou des trucs qui
allait de servir tout ali c'est à dire
te donner confiance en toi te permettre
de communiquer avec les autres en ayant
confiance dans les autres c'est à dire
au bout d'un moment de pouvoir échanger
en toute confiance donc redonner la
confiance que tu avais un peu perdue
dans le monde à duke aidants
monde extérieur on va dire travailler
sur la concentration sur l' écoute et
c'est donc qu'on a fait on fait plein de
jeux j'arrête la génération quand on
veut faire lafleur quand on se réveille
on le fait on flirte avec le métro bus
étaient bizarres et plein de trucs là me
rappelle il a dit fait alors vous êtes
une fleur vous naissez vous grandissez
puis vous mourrez aller vu qu'il ya des
choses que je devais jouer qu'ils
étaient des trucs que moi j'avais connu
j'avais juste à les remettre
mais du coup ça me faisait penser à
plein de trucs de ma vie bon du coup
c'est un peu aussi comme on dit mais
c'est vrai que ça te remémorés plein de
choses du coup c'est durant pu en même
temps c'est comme si ça te faisais un
travail sur toi enfin après les choses
deviennent moins dur pour toi chose qui
est avec lui tout seul et que tu t'en
sers pour jouer avec un coup ça devient
autre truc c'est une force qu'on va dire
ça donne un truc et pour moi ça fait la
naissance de l'acteur c'est pour ça que
c'est ça qui me qui m'a fasciné si tu
veux c'est de voir cette éclosion et
comme la fleur du butô tu vois ces voix
là j'ai vu en effet une fleur naître se
développer et grandir comme ça devant
mes yeux
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir filmer ça
ça a été une chance pour moi vraiment de
toi et d'adel de ce que vous m'avez
donné
instants précieux le temps du charisme
quant à jc à pied droit
sinon tant pis on cherchera par tous
il y aura bien par les trouver
ça implique tellement dans la seine que
tu dois jouer est tellement en
adéquation avec le personnage que tu
interprètes à ce moment là que d'un coup
il ya une magie qui s'opère voix il ya
quelque chose qui était de l'ordre de la
grâce pour moi comme ça qui m'intéresse
au cinéma c'est ça que je vais chercher
à révéler chez l'acteur donc je vais
essayer de lui donner la liberté le plus
de liberté possible pour qu'il puisse
justement me donner ces instants de
qu'ils font pour moi le cinéma pur que
la vérité
voilà c'est d'un coup sont quelque chose
qui transforme tu vois le le cinéma
professionnel tel convoi ou toi qui
montre le montre l'intériorité d'un être
humain voilà on intéresse c'est ça
dauger moi j'ai toujours recherché
je prenais je te promets que bientôt je
voudrais l'arrêt faut que je me fasse
agresser a pas le droit à des moments
tutu vit tellement la fen que tu vas
faire déjà l'avant ce que tu la vis des
chaînes tentent à tête avant et du coup
il ya des trucs à des scènes sont ces
super flipper dans partout ici qu'ils
allaient étudier ça sans quoi tu as tes
peu c'est pas un truc là quand la senza
pendaison dans les diacres voilà je veux
dire c'est trainer sur la scène de la
pendaison par exemple déjà j'ai peur je
vais mourir c'est psychologiquement on
voit tellement si dans le truc je vais
mourir
d'ailleurs j'ai fait un cauchemar quand
j'ai fini le film je crois que c'est ce
qu'on avait fait c'était la répète il
fallait tout refaire
et je voulais pas refaire de films après
déjà observant tout de suite après je
voulais plus refaire le film ça m'a
remis du temps au bout d'un an j'ai
commencé à me dire ah ben tiens ça me
manque
les tournages tout ça j'ai fait le
premier truc camille téléfilm avec la
suite brevets ça aller très très vite
c'est la télé donc je me rappelle par
exemple à insein où je vais pleurer
vois tu me mettez ces 1 minute 10
minutes avant dans une position si vous
étiez monter dans les larmes tout ça lui
non shining qui me faisait rien personne
ne disait rien c'était une sage de
vêtements lit en train de pleurer alors
ils m'ont mis dans le mille et puis
j'étais en train de préparer
l'alternance a à présent le motor home
ou non pas concentré à toul ar je me
mets donc pas le truc mon coussin je
voudrais surtout ici tous sortis je ne
me retourne j'ai pas trop les la
deuxième prise j'ai sorti un énorme mais
s'il classe pas ton tu as donc ça voilà
j'ai réussi à le faire mais il ya des
moments si tu peux pas réussir ou quand
il ya des gens il sort des blagues dans
l'équipe juste avant moteur avec
s'asseoir des 27 77 2 arrive pas et
encore des trucs
grâce à sa différence sur certains films
quand j'arrive sur un plateau ou
n'importe lesquels ont mis dans cet état
un peu comme ça je suis bien concentré
tout ça et puis après j'y vais un peu
quand je sens qu'on a monté à explorer
puis ça va être comme ça viendra mais
n'aborde même dans un étal une
concentration comme chez nous a appris
comment tu le met en condition les
fabricants que ça t'aide formatage à ça
me fait oublier tout le reste déjà tout
le reste et où j'ai vu mon des fois
c'est un peu dur parce que j'ai coché il
ya des vannes des trucs mais c'est vrai
que ça m j'arrive souvent oublié tout ça
quoi
et puis après je suis que le truc à
penser à marseille comment
gfr tard c'est que ça après une fois que
ça irait j'oublie tout jj cale à qui
c'est arrivé sur marcoule j'avais
seulement quinze jours
voilà c'était pas beaucoup et puis j'ai
fait sur trois mois au plus donc j'y
allais un jour donc je connaissais j'ai
quand même vite fait connu l'équipe
donc s'il n'y a pas beaucoup de jours
chaque fois que j'arrivais sinon j'ai
connaissez tous c'était bien l'ambiance
eux c'est vrai que j'étais un peu seul
quand on a son style heure pareille
oxygène sur un tournage
je suis entouré avec des adultes je suis
un peu seul
et puis avec beaucoup d'habitants connu
beaucoup directeur commis c'est vrai
beaucoup sur le canigou breitman jean
pierre cassel donne à tous le voir il ya
même à cotia mais la lame un petit truc
françois berléand et donc voilà j'étais
pas trop à l'aise parle tous tous ces
gens donc j'ai dû faire ma petite place
basket et chance et parmi elles et j'ai
attendu toute la journée pour un plomb
sûrement et qu'à l'arrivée ne le font
pas par exemple ça c'est qu'il va dire
ok tu sens foule de moi c'est bon c'est
vrai que tu as l'impression nationale
gbagbo
d'olmes et soco
le centre est
mon genou
o m
e
moi
c'est moi
que
je me préparais tout ça pour rencontrer
vanessa paradis est un samedi la
rencontre et j'avais déjà bossé masséna
exr j'étais prêt à envahir et puis après
je fais masséna et vanessa c'était toute
une journée
on a fait plusieurs scènes et à la fin
de la journée
vanessa elle a dit tu peux lire ces
maladies à serge après on me disait où
je leur disais non mais c'est trois
gamins ça marchera pas dans ce film
c'est pas ça drôle mais je sentais que
in fine est inexorablement quoi
hélas
il faut qu'on s'en aille
bien j'ai un ami de maman vient
donc je pense que tu as donné la clé où
tu as tort
elle est où cette [__] de clés
dans le monde change quand je vois ma
mère qui est morte sur un brancard
cette semaine je pleure et oum après je
vais être un quart d'heure chemin tous à
nous tous implorant de famille après sur
sorti dix minutes après parce que l'âge
est allé bien en dessous on tue ton ça
dépend avec qui tu arrêtes toi je mets
un peu sortait pourtant j'aime bien mon
t-shirt est directe vanessa lui disais
souvent tu te mets dans des états trop
second
c'est un film ne faut pas que tu
souffres etc etc alors qu'elle a des
façons de s'offrir différentes pour un
film et chez quelques années plusieurs
fois non ouais c'est être souffrait de
me voir dans quelques moments du film où
c'était douloureux pour le personnage
donc pour vincent à faire ça lui faisait
mal de penser qu'il souffrait autant le
mec à qui ça arrive et nous sommes visés
dans ce sens et du cinéma
parce que moi j'ai aller à fond et sa
part elle pourrait si j'y suis vraiment
pour moi quand il y avait un truc
c'était comme si c'était pour de vrai
alors j'y allais à fond elle m'a dit
c'est le cinéma et ça c'est vrai que
c'est un projet compris sur ce film sur
deux mais quand tu commencé avec un film
comme il ya six mois c'est pas ça cinéma
titre dino il faudra mode dans le truc
est tout en fait c'est du cinéma ce que
pourrait on peut te mettre de l'onu
s'est passé des trucs genre tu quand
vous serez à comprendre qu'il ya des
acteurs tu croyais sont super bons qu'en
fait ils arriveront l'ornement de vite
fait des petits trucs et c'est mon cas
mais j'ai peur moi que ces trucs là
c'est justement sa fausse moment
l'acteur nick tu vois et puis qui bons
plans afin que ce comment dire qui se
regarde tout le temps jouer tous les
trucs qui fait des représentations
ouais ouais moi en fait est ce que
c'était vraiment que tu voulais pour le
film parce que j'ai l'impression que ce
n'était pas moi qui ai costa au blizzard
pour moi obligé parce qu'on m'a dit si
c'est par un sens on fait pas le film
donc tu fais comme tu veux mais sinon tu
rentres chez toi et donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle une obligation non mais ce que
je peux dire en fait parce que lui
souhaiter belle carrière et tout ça pour
quoi
moi ce que je peux dire c'est meilleur
c'est que
quand on a fait le film il avait 17 ans
j'en avais un peu plus mais bizarrement
j'ai et j'ai l'impression qu'il m'a plus
après que moi j'ai pu apprendre si tu
veux toi qu'à fermer la porte et moi si
tu veux je vais demander un autre le
tient peut être un tueur
je lui dirai s'est pressé qu'il faut
qu'ils vont tout de suite quatre appels
au secours
je sais pas comment faire
m
t'as qu'à te faire comme si j'étais un
autre
si j'avais été recherchées ge est
arrivée en courant c'est même à cause de
ça parce que j'ai cool jet turquie temps
c'est pas du tout parce que j'ai peur je
te montre plus t'as pas peur
si tu ferme la porte ça pourrait
ressembler un peu
gb
je crois qu'il faut concerner donc après
le moment il ya eu la maison nina
richard nabot il ne disait pas trop de
pas trop de choses me rappellent même un
joueur jensen il vient de jours après la
scène y ait une vie tu vois tu menais de
la poussière de bord moi je veux la
poussière de diamant je fais mes fans me
dire sur le moment où tu vois c'est pas
du genre à préférer c'est trop tard puis
le visage allemagne donc moi j'allais
pouvoir mais les crues et universal bon
en même temps ça m'a fait cogiter et
tout ce qu'on m'a dit ou peut-être
qu'après on fait bien moins cher arriver
c'est encore une fois ça m'a fait pas de
questions ils voient la déstabiliser à
son titre avait toujours quelqu'un pour
l'histoire le ps de jouer
voilà par exemple là dans le film il
pense que son père est mort mon père est
décédé aussi est en fait là c'est sa
mère qui est décédée
pour moi ça me fait faire un truc ça me
paraît déjà fin et parce que oui les
délais lui y croit que son père est mort
ça pour moi c'est un truc que je sais ce
que si j'arrivais après c'était en fait
sa mère donc là ça me fait un autrui
comme un diable
pas de doute pas tu dis pas qu est ce
que je vais devoir faire une envie qui
t'a rien besoin de faire tu sais j'ai
vécu ça à un besoin de faire c'est tout
qu'est-ce que qu'après 10 ou 20 enfants
déportés pas déporter cachet visuel vous
préférez jouer alors fondé porter ça
j'aurais pu faire pourquoi mais en fait
tu dis ça mais quand j'ai lu le scénario
j'ai voulu gabriel il m'a dit ça tombe
bien le réalisateur parce qu'on voyait
pour gabriel parce qu'on va c'est
l'histoire du père et tout ça donc ça me
parait joie est histoire pour me mais en
fait un enfant des portes et c'est un
plus pour moi c'était plus plusieurs
coiffure est de se sentir à neuf c'est
comme si tu as été dans les contenus
je les nourris corps sur les jouets soir
façon tous les films avec les enfants
qui ont des vies et des durs mongi
turcotte son enfant une enfance gâchée
quoi ça m'intéresse tous ces rôles font
pareil tout ça en dessous des buts comme
ça
faussement 10 + 100 kg joue un petit
bourg je m'intéresse moi tu réforme
reprochant 3 sur son approche que tu
vois on tire sans faire le mec a une
enfance gâchée même raison le pire mais
quand même c'est des choses que je peux
y chercher savais que les gars que j'ai
compris ça et c'est ce que j'ai fait
pour les yeux et j'ai vécu et c'est
comme ça qu'on besoins des cantons
quand on sort notre calme enfin les
vrais trucs les notions qui sont proches
on va même pas tricher en fait un vrai
voilà j'aime paris et c'est ça faire
semblant et tout mais je vois qu'on me
demande des fois sur des trucs de faire
semblant qu'il fait moi je préfère quand
c'est vraiment vrai quoi
j'ai vu les diables je l'avais vachement
envie de vincent voilà il y avait un
autre film que celle que j'avais vu et
qui m'avait c'était ce qui m'avait plu
et puis vincent il était un peu lassé un
sweet sixteen de ken loach
voilà et je trouvais que ken loach et
film magnifiquement les les adolescents
je trouvais qu'il y avait un truc qui
répondait avec avec les diables quoi
enfin et que vincent correspondait à ça
et j'avais une autre idée de jeunes qui
étaient absolument pas comme vincent
c'était peut-être le contraire de
vincent c'était un film qui s'appelle
warzone de tim roth où il ya un jeune
adolescent qui a enfin je sais pas il ya
un peu la même brutalité dans le jeu la
même truc comme ça mais c'était pas du
tout j'ai un jeune adolescent comme
savaient qu avec une belle gueule comme
dance with the sweet sixteen c'était
vraiment le le type beaucoup plus
renfermé avec avec avec des boutons
voilà en pleine période ingrate de
l'adolescence alors parle un peu de la
rencontre avec eric eric aussi les coûts
sans vie voilà ça tu sens que tu peux
donner qui peuvent leur faire confiance
que voit répit lui il était vraiment un
fond dans son film façon
ça sent pas bien c'est que s'affrontent
lice à ce voyou les filles qui lui
tenaient à coeur
chi minh et il sort des tripes ça se
voit donc là tu as envie de tout donner
peut-être l'allier tu vois c'est ce qui
s'est passé avec eric brass ans à
l'acteur c'est un homme pudique et la
pudeur je trouve que c'est c'est super
mais c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
faire sortir les choses avec quelqu'un
de pudique
en même temps quand elles sortent elles
sont il ya l'antagonisme nécessaire qui
fait que que c'est très beau pour moi
parce que quelqu'un qu'il pleure je
deviens voilà tu dis un acteur de
ploeren mais qui pleurent facilement ils
pleurent rient pleurent et puis tu as
envie de lui tendre un mouchoir et et
voilà c'est vrai je sais j'en ai aussi
lucas qu'est ce qui se passe et revoit
sa manière toute pastiche narac
maintenant tu comprends rien je crois
qu'il est là pourquoi thomas
depuis le début nous a menti j'en ai
mort son frère
eric il m'a dit je te demande pas de
jouer 2g pas que tu dis ça essaye de
comprendre cette somme pas que tu joues
la cormier donc quand même penser que la
foudre être là je dois dire ça comme ça
c'est quoi pas jouer tu vois si elle est
appelée le trick septembre où il tissait
plus c'est d'accord je fais quoi tu
ville truc en fait ça peut être ça
surement mais mais même tu peux pas
vivre le truc fort cette chasse tu paies
certains trucs les vivres c'est vrai on
est obligé de penser que la face à ça ça
veut dire en fait remonter la roule ma
mobylette je peux faire est obligé de
penser quoi qui est une caméra retire
les tu peux pas faire n'importe quoi
vous montrer quoi moi tu ne dis pas en
maintient la photo mc la droite au delà
évitons truc qui ne jouent pas d'accord
j'ai pas de métier la droite qui a foutu
trois tiennent quand on dit de courir à
fond quand fait foule tu coures pas du
tout à fond selectrip foule sur jouer un
petit peu
ou quand je parlais de la mobylette
parce que je pensais à 1,5010 à une fois
je me rappelle il disait vincent force
plus quand tu fais ta longue lettre de
vivre le truc parce que moi le truc j'ai
peint doit forcer comme un malade pour
visser je prends comme ça je me dis que
tu vois il vous les mains parce qu'à
l'image faut forcer pour qu'on voit bien
que les trucks et ça paraît pas naturel
pour moi c'est être naturel quand il
nous dit pas
ce qui était bizarre c'était de jouer
avec lui parce qu'il savait que c'était
le réalisateur et des fois je le voyais
me regarder en fait quand on était
ensemble dans une scène je voyais que
des fois je lui disais mais je devais me
retourne pour le dire la phrase à lui
devrait qui m'ont regardé jouer presque
donc ça ça ne te fait penser tu penses à
tiendra trois mariages ou et donc du
coup ça tend un tout petit peu de ton de
talent mais voit ses trucs ça s'apprend
un millième de seconde
toi tu penses a vite fait après tu l'as
jeu c'est une antiquité ton truc c'est
richard le copain de jeanne qui me
l'avait offert et nuit je n'arrivais pas
à dormir ça me travaille alors j'ai
pensé à soigner tôt j'ai commencé à toi
enregistrés dans la salle du café
il a du souffle c'est pas très bonne
qualité ce genre mieux que le
bourdonnement gelato j'ai plein de
cassettes dans le registre quoi un peu
tous sur tous les clients mais ce qui
était bien aussi c'est qu'il faisait que
à la fin des prises on pouvait
improviser un petit peu avec des fois il
obtint des trucs vraiment sincère
pendant le film et hindi brigands
n'était pas écrit et moi j'ai fait un
gros rire sur les golfs un vrai avenir
tu vois là c'était moi vraiment brigands
quand je dis en fait moi c'est quand je
me pose pas la question
voilà c'est classé revient direct je me
suis même pas posé de dire je vais faire
faire et donc ça c'était bien avec eric
parce qu'il ya plein de moments vrais
tuerait dans l'oeuf et le moment où on
est au restaurant chinois tous tous les
deux on mange aussi j'avais fait tourner
aussi la caméra sont en faisant des
répètes etc
c'était une prise qui étais tu vois et
voilà et ça par exemple cessé résistance
quand on va dans le sourire quand on va
dans le rire quand on va dans la joie
quelque chose comme ça cc résistance à
lui la difficulté je trouve pour le
point quelqu'un qu'il le dirige c'est ça
de lui donner suffisamment confiance
pour se permettre d'aller là dedans on
n'a pas profité pour voir sa copine ce
soir elle est peut-être venir je vais
pas lui ça ressemble à quoi
une grande brune avec année assez
particulière mais moi j'aime bien
alarmant toshirô neutre
cheveux courts et avait souvent un
bonnet et surtout à un beau sourire
enfin je la trouve belle c'est toi qui
l'a draguée way jours après le sortir
ensemble
elle travaille sa concentration elle est
très forte à vincent avant fin mai elle
est forte aussi en fin de quasiment tout
le temps enfin disons que c'est un bon
allié ouais c'est vrai qu'il est très
concentré je me souviens de la scène où
ils pleuraient ou tu pleurais sur le
lille quand tu tombes sur la lettre
c'était c'était super et la manière dont
on est allé se concentrait là tous les
deux quand même là là là en tant que
réalisateur tu pousses la technique quoi
il ya des sa loge où je vais être
derrière la caméra juste pour dire la
réplique
moi je vais la donner à fond je me
remette dans l'étape j'étais si j'étais
en train de pleurer leurs plus rien si
je passe devant la caméra pour donner
tout à l'autre et ça va l'aider ça va
faire qu'il va sortir des choses alors
que thomas ils s'en foutent ils arrivent
et il se matérialise le texte comme ça
presque ils le disent qu'ils se trompent
d'intérêt à tâtons plan sur toi dont il
s'en fout en face c'est quoi pour toi
vraiment le métier d'acteur c'est de se
mettre dans une autre vie tu pars sur un
tournage dans ta tête tu as un
personnage pieds tu es avec lui dans ta
tête tu vois c'est à dire des fruits
frais soit il ferait ça
il fera parce que je suis en train de
faire face à plus tôt c'est ça en fait
un autre personnalité qui rentrent en
fait l'impact sur ta propre vie
c'est à dire tous ces personnages toutes
ces rencontres est ce que tu sens comme
ça tu apprends des choses sur la vie que
tu ferais pas sinon voilà du coup çi
c'est un peu aussi des fois tu sais pas
comment être un monde sur toi même tu as
vu plein de vita et landes dans d'autres
visions du monde la vie qu'on va dire je
ne peux pas les choses de manière
continue un personnage un autre qui dit
comment voir les chaussures mais
tellement de façons de voir les choses
du coup tu as encore plus ouvert 28 je
comprends plus moche et pas à cela on
vient un des plus ouvertes
t'es pas dans un seul truites et 1,8 à
mutavie cnaf a pas élection c'est un peu
ça talent et une autre vie quoi
et comme souvent c'est fondamental pour
ton regard extérieur qui te dit tu peux
faire mieux ou ça s'est super bien c'est
surtout seul ne peut pas savoir
je suis très fière d'y construire mais
il ya des fois je me regarde jouer toi
et tu vas enfin je souffre je n'étais
pas dedans à la leçon mais même ça tu
dis à l'arrivée les gens éloignés mais
ça se passe soit ça qui est donc tu sais
pas il n'y a pas de migros et je sais
pas ce qu'il faut faire voter ses idées
rupture tu étais j'ai retrouvé dans la
position où la peur est tellement grande
que tu arrives tu la joues et tu as
oublié de s'arrêter pendant un moment de
retrouver un peu des fois ça arriver où
je pleure dirait qu'un enfin toi ça m'a
mis les nerfs est toujours largement
tout ça nous met tout seul car je sais
pas je sent pas le truc on ne va pas le
jouer
puis là on oublie son spin il faut y
aller tout inquiète pas attendre avec
une peinture est de bon ton toi tu sais
qu'il ne sent pas le truc là et c'est là
tout de suite que je dois le faire mais
tu te sens pas prêt et où il a commis
est là mais l'entretien est avalée tu
vois tu sais pas si ça va aller
tu arrives tu fais ton truc impressionna
font n'importe comment et qu'il te reste
est générale et tout cela hockey acih
c'était génial
problème ouais c'est pour ça que tu
rebaptise parce que toi on trouve ça
génial même pas des mots est en fait tu
as l'impression tout et prend en traître
lentement que tu as fait de la grosse
merde des clients ils sont gentils avec
toi
donc du coup tu es perdu
est-ce que ça tu as peur justement de te
perdre là-dedans et si tu trouves
d'avoir un doute sur les gens s'ils sont
sincères ou pas d'avenir superbe parce
que j'ai l'impression de plus ça va être
plus vivant et sincère avec moi à oui
depuis film avec vanessa a changé
beaucoup de tous les gens là le regard
des tonnages là tu fais ça tu as fait
et ça ça te plait ça te fait mal mais ça
j'aime pas ça qu'est ce que tu sens
c'est fou quand on en vient à
l'importance d'avoir un regard d'un
fille art sur le plateau qui permettent
aux protégés un peu tout ça va te dire
il faut que je fasse confiance je tire
la vérité à dire si ce que je fais c'est
bien vraiment tout ça ça c'est oublier
que je sais pas si j'ai ça mal assumé un
set up
je vais essayer des choses ont posé
plusieurs choses
je vais pouvoir aller plus loin j'aurais
pas peur tu as une question de se sentir
en confiance ou pas quoi
passons à lire votre réseau après les
maniements d'armes par exemple les
choses non j'ai pas j'ai pas d'armes
j'ai juste mais maintenant j'ai pas
appris mais des petites chorégraphe de
cascades une petite vite fait je suis un
mec qui est sûre on ne le souhaite sur
le gars de la trappe par derrière c'est
de l'étrangler après antoine a pu
traverser une palissade bas mon exposé
la palissade on roule un petit peu voilà
il y avait ma doublure et après il ya le
mec qui est sur moi je suis toujours
comme ça lui est sûrement et là ils
essayent sur son flingue up essaie de m
il fait qu' il ya pas de balle qui sort
après je voyais à un autre mec qui
arrive donc vite le mec je me suis moi
l'autre mec en face ils firent bamba
triste quand la balle bon après je
prends le pistonné je jette sur leur
enfance c'est une chorégraphie vivre
c'était bien mais même le truc du du mal
à vous je j'ai il y avait des câbles à
certaines prises t'es sur le mât on se
pouvait patron de faire mal c'était pas
trop pas trop haute mais à l'arrivée
j'arrivais à l'eau en dessous je
pourrais tourner bon bah je les fais
sans fil et que les fini qu'elle donc
sage et tu vas voir dans le film tu
verras jim hawkins qui fait l'équilibré
il est vraiment fait ça des trucs comme
5e
tu vas revenir à peine une semaine à
paris et tu repars sur un autre film
dans un monde complètement différent de
livres 13 ans aspach à la garde c'est
fini la ventura c'est la guerre c'est
une aventure volumes et notre centre
aventure voilà je pense qu'ils vont me
raser les cheveux déjà ça soit un mètre
carré dans un autre pays ennemi intime
benoît magimel albert dupontel sava film
sur la guerre d'algérie
réalisé par florent emilio siri syrie il
n'ya pas pire ennemi que soi même c'est
la première phrase que tu vois moi je
fais un jeune français qui a appelé pour
aller à la guerre d'algérie
ils ont pas si des des documentaires de
regarder tel ça fait travailler
préparation d'un personnage on va te
conduire à mieux comprendre le
personnage mais en plus tu apprends plus
de choses dans la vie voit donc ça c'est
ça j'aime bien le faire contraire c'est
ce que je demande seulement et bien
faire comme au dernier au café pour taxi
la river il a fait taximan pendant trois
ou quatre mois je suis pas aussi faire
des trucs comme ça j'aime bien ce que
j'aimerais surtout faire que vrai que
d'arriver on demande juste de faire la
colère ou des vraiment préparé tu vois
pendant ce temps j'ai pas vraiment
encore ça tu vois un schizophrène tu
vois tu vas voir un de ce qu'ils au
titre des recherches les détruit à cela
c'est vraiment intéressant
brad est vraiment tu vois tu vis une
autre victoire
j'aimerais bien faire un film
tidjane thiam télé fric ça j'aimerais
bien faire une bonne fille
un bon film d'action tu vois on sera
plein de trucs des pistolets fruits mais
soumise à bien et après c'est vrai film
intime presque augmenté
ça va loin dans le jeu de l'acteur soit
aussi faire un choix les deux quoi pas
un seul truc surtout comédie aventure
tristram atik action pack ouais mais on
m'a parlé de genre nous convier marlon
brando pousse à marlon brando tout cela
j'ai fait des trucs et marlon brando
jour rien détruire l'appareil s'il est
vrai c'est que l'art c'est sous ces
grand robert de niro pacino clint
eastwood quitte à nouveau les gars qui
tu sens que même il serait pas faire du
chiffre et pas du cinéma sa fraîche et
ce serait des grands-crus il aurait rêvé
ça serait un jour de pouvoir être un des
grands acteurs comme alors fait que ça a
changé du cinéma alors des électeurs
j'aimerais bien faire partie de ces
grands acteurs de fleurs dans une
histoire à voir et après tellement les
acteurs
sortir du lot c'est dur et ce avec leur
star system tout ça mais dans un truc je
bouge plus vous rentrez l'hébreu et
sarah pour l'instant je ne pleure pas
c'est des branques se contente tous les
rôles que j'ai fait peut-être le
téléfilm que je devrais être un petit
peu j'aime tous les autres là je suis
content même darcos un petit truc je
suis content surtout les diables c'est
sûr qu'elle ça c'est plus gros pour moi
j'ai fait à présent c'est à présent
c'est plus que pour certains c'est pas
pour les gens ils n'ont peut-être pas se
dire ça à mon avis franchement si les
diables bleus plusieurs plus gros et 63
jours où j'ai donné plus pour
l'association aussi j'aimerais bien
faire des films par an où j'écris je
rigole en permanence d'un film tu vois
où chaque éclat de rire message éclaté
en larmes tous déjà fait mais éclaté
derrière je n'ai pas encore fait mon
choix
il ya des trucs j'aimerais savoir si je
suis capable de faire plein de choses
on verra comme ça se passe
puis surtout moi ce que je fais c'est
entrer dans la sphère du déménagement où
je suis et d'autres trucs parce qu'elle
avait dit le cinéma ça peut s'arrêter
demain à charge des médias que tout ça
c'est si beau mon type je vais raku
déménagement déménageurs à coup je fais
caissier je passe un maçon plomberie
stade tout dit man dans un film on peut
un jour demandé de faire un plombier tu
vois moi sur la couverture assez
résistant rigolant mais c'est vrai que
des fois je me dis ça ils ont fait tout
un ses goûts ses mailles 60 petits
métiers encore un premier tournage voilà
qui voudra ce que je suis pas que dans
le truc de l'acteur cinéma tu as qui
veut mettre un peu parce que c'est un
autre monde aussi publié vite fait quoi
ça ça aide à 4 mètres dans la réalité
c'est le 17 juin 1986 le parquet mois
sur ce psg star et antiquités sont
sérieuses critiques ne va pas jusque là
plus mature avec que les proches et je
suis allé ce type at elle se fit
aussitôt viré aussi que rempli avec pour
seul objectif sans sortir du mois
minimum sopo est très serein texte lui
dire là dessus
dépourvu par ce fait chic j'en ai eu
autant le litre un média qui fait que
les s'efface pour de telles que la hire
principe qu écrivent hatcher est bien là
d'une autre ça j'ai peine avais je gère
la société
c'était un problème
quatre solutions